trust me you aren't the only person
still looking at the tesla cyber truck
and pondering why or how it looks the
way it does and it's even very likely
that you have already read about it
several times and discussed it with your
buddies you might have even contemplated
pre-ordering one a day later or you're
one of those 300 000 enthusiasts who
ordered it in its first week of launch
however the one thing you probably still
need to do is learn more about the cyber
trucks makeup in order to have a strong
opinion about it cybertruck is a stroke
of genius that was designed by tesla in
november 2019. it is a stainless steel
angular and all-electric pickup truck
its launch didn't go smoothly the
truck's window was shattered when its
lead designer smashed it with a metal
ball making elon musk infamously curse
under his breath nevertheless cyber
truck pre-orders approached an
unprecedented 250 000 within a week of
its launch it witnessed an explosion of
interest devoid of advertising musk the
tesla founder revealed that he wants
cybertruck to be a leader when it comes
to trucks for consumer use now watch on
as i explain the reasons why tesla
cybertruck is a stroke of genius welcome
back to our channel if you haven't
already make sure you hit the subscribe
button and ring that bell so you're
notified every time we upload a new
video as with anything unfamiliar and
new public opinion is always split but
it's not exactly the same on this tesla
master stroke hate it or love it the
cyber truck is revolutionary it's
clearly designed to be one of the best
trucks on the market for commercial and
consumer use especially in the near
future without much ado here's why
tesla's cyber truck is a stroke of
genius cyber truck pushes the limit
tesla cyber truck has pushed some design
limits in the automobile industry to the
extent that the previously controversial
idea has been adopted as industry
standards as the norm this cyber truck
is so bold extreme and polarizing that
no automobile company would dare to copy
the design in other words tesla cyber
truck designs are too unique and
represent the high standards the company
is known for also tesla integrated many
technologies into one offering
cybertruck has the same stainless steel
alloy used at musk's sister company
spacex the truck has lithium-ion
batteries hardware and software for
self-driving plus a solar roof choice to
boost the truck's range according to
musk cybertruck isn't designed to blend
in it was manufactured to be extreme and
break from the norm exoskeleton
tesla cyber truck is designed with
exterior shelves for passenger
protection and ultimate durability in
other words it has an almost
impenetrable exoskeleton all components
are made for superior endurance and
strength from ultra hard 30x cold rolled
stainless steel skin to the armored
glass polarizing
polarizing is one of the perks of the
cyber truck and once fully implemented
it could be a great move from the tesla
team tesla's limit push with cybertruck
is insane and set to transform the
automobile industry the aim is to break
the existing expectation uniquely to
pave a path for the great future and a
perfect way to break through is via
polarizing with polarizing the truck can
carry more tow more and can be much
quicker significantly it compares in
distance travel per tank at 500 range
miles the commercial especially the
military buyers have been the main
customer base it arguably beat the
rivian rit electric car the cyber truck
reaches 60 miles per hour in 6.5 seconds
carries 3 500 pounds in its base model
and weighs about 7 500 pounds
distinctive features
musk's cyber truck idea was extreme to
design a truck quicker than a porsche
911 and stronger than an f-150 his major
aim was to have competitive advantages
over two prominent products the truck's
appearance follows one logic it has an
extreme planar design it has nothing
round and has no smooth edge the truck's
exoskeleton is designed from stainless
steel plates made for spacex rockets
this enables huge cost savings and
obviating paint jobs with major
structural benefits cybertruck can seat
six adults the built-in air compressor
lets the truck outperform the other
trucks in the market moreover the
truck's huge battery pack is especially
fitted for v2g use as hinted the truck
has a 120 volt 240 volt ac power outlet
that could power homes and blackouts in
another vein because of its size and
weight the truck might be less efficient
than electric passenger cars available
now but when compared to other
non-electric trucks it would be better
due to the inherent efficiency of the
electric vehicles and aerodynamics it is
important to add that the truck's
interior is roomy while featuring the
17-inch signature central touch pad
versatile utility
another reason why this truck is genius
is because of its versatile utility it
has about 3 500 pounds of payload
capacity plus an adjustable air
suspension moreover it's designed with
100 exterior cubic feet and lockable
storage that's strong standing
cybertruck also has rugged strength it
can pull near infinite mass with a
towing ability of more than 14 000
pounds importantly the truck can easily
perform in any extreme situation as
stated cyber truck has an adaptive air
suspension it comes with a lever and
raises suspension four inches in any
direction for simple access to the vault
also the self-leveling capability can
adapt to various occasions another great
feature of this truck is its awesome
adaptability from refined to rugged the
truck is adaptable to your requirements
you can get ready for any experience
with a versatile utilitarian design like
the compressed air and onboard power
leveraging pop culture
the tesla ceo understands pop culture
power now cyber truck takes this culture
to a higher level the truck looks like a
blade runner in particular the movie's
post-apocalyptic vibe inspires the
truck's design and even the launch event
interestingly the truck's unique visual
language makes for an excellent canvas
for some user-generated content just
like the tesla cars acceleration modes
are called plaid insane and ludicrous
straight from the spaceballs movie these
pop culture references are great for
advertisement and business for cyber
truck ultra hard 30x cold rolled
stainless steel
the stainless steel aids in eliminating
damage dense and long-term corrosion
using a smooth monochrome exoskeleton
the exoskeleton puts a shell on the
truck's outside to provide maximum
protection to the driver and passengers
this ultra hard 30x cold rolled
stainless steel according to musk makes
the truck bulletproof the truck is
resistant to nine millimeter ammunition
and common rounds fired from handguns
and machine guns before i end this let
me add that tesla has significant
advantages that would make the cyber
truck the best truck even in years to
come the first one is that tesla the
producer of cyber truck has an extensive
and advanced charging network that helps
truck owners quickly refuel in the
meantime over 14 000 superchargers are
available globally another advantage is
that tesla has deeply invested in
battery manufacturing and technology the
truck's gigafactory expands and it uses
more renewable energy like solar power
to lessen battery ecological footprints
thus tesla can scale up its production
and could reduce its truck's prices even
lower than its competitors significantly
just like other tesla cars this truck
can attain a fully self-driving
capability tesla's autopilot system and
cars presently lie at partial automation
or level 2. they are self-driving but
haven't reached level 5. level 5 is the
highest level of autonomy for
self-driving cars this level entails
that the car can be fully self-driving
it can do all the driving in any
circumstance it's worthy to note that
this cyber truck and its expanding
offerings by other electric vehicle
manufacturers represent the start of a
higher transition away from the internal
combustion engine we sure have to see a
self-driving truck soon when tesla
revealed this genius cyber truck design
in november 2019 many people saw it as a
joke especially in its first week of
release it looks somewhat colorless so
minimal and has just a normal design
outlook the truck consists of flat
planes thus some people assumed it was
childlike and thoughtless in its outlook
now it's clear that tesla's cyber truck
reeks of efficiency and performance the
truck joins the new class of vehicles
with speed strength and versatility made
with an all-electric design cybertruck's
strong drivetrain and its low center of
gravity offer great traction and control
and torque that enables acceleration
from 0 to 60 miles per hour to 500 miles
of range as said at the beginning of the
video it's just a stroke of genius by
all standards what other unique features
do you know about the cyber truck do you
see it as the best truck ever we want to
hear your opinion on this leave us a
comment below and if you enjoyed this
video make sure to give it a like and
check out more awesome ones on the
simply tech channel thanks for watching
and we'll see you next time